this video is brought to you by Babel
and better help more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it's me Terra ericon alongside these
guys we're going to let s 10 say your
names I'm John You Know Me
Maybe I'm Aaron I'm I come here
sometimes ah oh my gosh you guys John
has been with us actually from the
beginning behind the scenes edit down
most all of our saw reactions for me and
Aaron the thumbnails he's worked on it
he's been in the juice in the
environment with us so he is here today
to watch 10 we are so stoked for the
final thing you guys you better leave a
like you better leave a comment you
better ring the
bell ring the bell W that was so good I
love that also thanks prep for helping
us at down these videos also don't
forget we call you super sexy you get on
the patreon you get
sexy and you can sne up with your own
copy watch uh the old sou with all three
of us which will be awesome also uh Greg
and John offer exclusive highlights and
watch alongs over there on patreon so
get over there get sexy if you know
what's good for you speaking of Greg
just real quick want to shout out the
man Greg we wanted to have him here we
wanted to do like a Quadra Force I'm
heartbroken we both love the sauce so
just if you're watching this just leave
some Greg love down in the comments cuz
he's out there he's taking meetings and
making arrangements so that we all can
be here enjoying with you guys so give
the man some love
love you guys I was scream crying in the
corner prying to hear that he is not
going to join us today but it's G to be
all right we'll be
okay um also what else should I say uh
we're just we're sad it's going to end
and hopefully we get on another Series
right yeah anybody want to say any last
things before we watch it it's been
great it let's play game let's play a
game
I've been waiting for this same I keep
seeing it on AMC and I'm like I want to
see it but no I must be patient must
be John
fer got to get your sinuses aligned I
did did not like seeing him upside down
I don't suppose you can tell me how it
looks can you unfortunately I'm just the
technician your doctor will have your
results tomorrow it looks great though
don't don't even trip you're very
kind remember that that tumor in your
brain cancer has brought grief and pain
and fear into my every waking moment
today is a gift that's why they call it
the present bars
bars big bars Sage wisdom Henry Kesler
stage four pancreatic terminal that's
what they tell me anyway but I'm going
to fight this to the end all right
another support group it's an Easter egg
you guys how much time do I have months
at best I still have a lot of work that
needs to be done my advice retire that's
my friend David Alano was in Saw 10
crazy so you actually know that guy
finally
did you warn him what's going to happen
to him if he doesn't take good care of
John I haven't so your advice to me is
to die easy you're the first one
trapped bad advice it's crazy how this
man has been doing Saw movies for 20
years and his not age today they keep
him looks the
same oh no man what are you doing bro
for
real
oh my God like also aren't there cameras
also you suck someone's going to notice
this at some
point really
wow oh my God God
dang it's interesting now to see like
healing devices looking like torture oh
God
no oh no we're already here oh
jeez
ha karma [__] Karma baby exactly got
the inspiration right from the the
patient
damn I'd like to play a game yeah yeah
baby you said the thing I've had my eyes
on you and I do not like what I see your
job as a custodian is a noble one
sanitizing and sterilizing the hospital
oh my God helping patients avoid
sickness but there is a sickness inside
you that needs to be excised you have
the ability to not only save your soul
today but your sight
exed click the dial across the five
positions and you will live to see
another day oh Christ you have 60
seconds he ain't going to make it bro
you would have turned that dial oh my
God no oh my God is this just a shot
back it's going to suck it out oh my God
oh you knew this was coming Pete oh my
god
oh
oh oh
yeah the hot head shot oh I can't I I
can't God thank you so
creative
[Music]
God Jesus I hate
this no no no this is so awful oh my God
you're
[__] Jesus oh my goodness only one
eye oh the other one nope
nope my my
gosh that was insane please tell me that
that was a Flash Forward and not just a
fanty and not just to like maybe I'll do
this a he's just a fantasy damn oh wow
that was a good choice very
inventive live or die I'll I'll take it
it was still a good trap I'll take wow
that was a great trap and it's a good
window into John's mind I love that he
saw the the traction on the fingers it
informs the Trap itself like good [__]
so good
thank
you just a little French press
coffee he a sophisticated man John
CR man of class that coffee was in his
last will in
tes Henry we were in the same cancer
support group John Kramer this guy's
familiar too You Look Marvelous I feel
great correct me if I'm wrong but you
were yeah stage four pancreatic but now
4 months later I'm in complete remission
what wa that's insane how it's a long
story i' love to hear it you got a
minute to tell me horse
steroids he just drank a lot of green
tea I read about a doctor he went to
Nicaragua Finn Peterson he offered a
treatment it is a groundbreaking drug
cocktail combined with surgery
oh interesting coffee first then torture
who it's my war wound it looks bad but
it was totally worth it is it available
here the treatment's not available in
the states the uh the medication isn't
approved by the FDA it's usually how it
goes put the whole FDA in a trap yeah I
um haven't seen them since my treatment
in Norway
but John just go to carage I know
there's some people out there treat you
nice oh my God we're not Savages jigsaw
strange I'm here for
it traps with magic oh my
God it's still
good good luck man I'm rooting for you
oh boy they did a good job at really
looking him making him look sick this
time yeah and he looks really sad too
like I really feel what he's going
through right now yeah I like that we're
living living in in his shoes like
finally kind of for once in a more human
way under the right circumstances and
with the proper stimuli jeans can be
turned on and turned off like a light
switch is this like crisper guys know
crisper everyone loves crisper what we
managed to do is to create a new
cuttingedge drug cocktail along with
surgery to teach the malignant cells
switch off wonder how much medical
research they did on this my father Dr
Finn Peterson was forced into hiding by
corrupt governments and their
relationship to Big farmer put him in a
trap because my father was on the cusp
of curing dozens of diseases can you
imagine what that implies well the big
drug company certainly
can I'm taking his treatment on the road
for more trials to save as many lives as
humanly possible road show let's do this
next up John Kramer sorry I'm just I'm
just imagining Cartage traps now your
limbs the sling ring will close around
your neck severing your head in a
different
Universe we received the email with your
medical records so I'm calling you now
because we have spots opening for
treatment in about 3
months too long too late I got a bunch
of conflicting traps around then you
don't have 3 months do you but we have a
team of Specialists here gathered a
group of eligible patients to start
treatment a week from now I think I
could add one more spot could you tell
me a little more about the treatment oh
boy it's a two-prong treatment that uses
my father's seop phenol cocktail and in
your case it would be combined with a
cranial surgery to clear the tumor we've
been there but I want you to know that
we found a very beautiful locasion for
our Clinic outside Mexico City oh good
glad it's pretty what date did you have
in mind oh he's like he's getting choked
up the fifth Friday After Next I think I
could make that he might live to see
another day maybe he'll make it this
time trap making
yes maybe this is a different Universe
yeah it's going to set up a whole new
timeline oh dang saw on the
road
soxo Baka take a look at that that's a
metropolitan Cathedral nice that's a
cool shot yeah that's the olastic stat
of FL that's where the priest Cho the
heart out of their subjects and roll in
them the huh damn new game awaits yes I
think they originally wanted to shoot
this this stuff set this in Prague and
then they had to switch to Mexico at a
later point or something okay but I love
the vibe I like seeing International saw
yeah yeah me too hey gay you
okay [__] no thank you it's a trap pigs
come
out the ma get out Jesus what the what's
your name John Kramer Li to me again and
I this chamber in your ey I'm not lying
my name is Johan Kramer not to worry s
krer you're fine you're safe what what
what what the hell that's even more
disconcerting right depending on how we
feel this is either a kidnap van or a
rescue
van
huh
your room here probably because the
doctor had to go into hiding so they
have to like throw people off the scent
I guess and they must have arranged the
taxi and he must have known where he was
going I am John Kramer
come hi gabri this movie takes its time
and I like it yeah yeah like there's and
it's like still I feel it like guess
it's good he
me fromia like even though they're
taking their time it doesn't feel slow
Dr Cecilia Peterson she save life my
life I get I get now yeah this is
fascinating cuz this is the first time
I've ever like oh hope he makes it you
know they really putting him as the the
lead of this whole thing really
interesting Mr
Kramer
welcome oh oh dude but we've had to beef
up the security wherever we go the big
drug companies are always one step
behind we must keep our location secret
from everyone even you which is no small
feat I tell you and they're good at
selling you the hope of like I I know
this is all going to go bad but like I'm
hopeful at the moment living in his hope
which is smart our local football star
his father is a
caretaker I'm hopeful for John but I
have a bad feeling about everyone else
here not that not that they're bad not
suspicious but something bad's going to
happen okay maybe the people try to the
pharmacy people come and then John sets
up a bunch of Pharmacy traps and kills
them all yes take all these pills yeah
takes Revenge traps exactly
yeah people love SAU six you
know whoa so Advanced mattio is an
anesthesiologist at hospital alge he did
his residency at Johns Hopkins
has worked a lot with my father damn
love me some anesthesia this is
Valentina one of our nurses she'll be
taking some scans and drawing some blood
all in preparation for the injection
therapy later today excellent he's clear
for release wonderful excellent
P John Kramer that was
[Laughter]
Corney don't be coughing near me bro C
me up from yesterday oh took out a tumor
the size of my knob oh wow they're a
type of cytotoxic
lymphocytes I've been a civil engineer
and an architect most of my life and a
dungeon
master now I have a few
Hobbies I I re rehabilitate the wicked I
help people overcome inner obstacles
classic car
inovation sometimes involving a car make
positive changes in their lives like a a
life coach yeah or life
dying a life
doua
a you speak English
Carlos okay that's about as good as my
Spanish how do you say
pull pull pull pull
Hala H Duo jigsaw or today's video
sponsor
Babel
okay
voila
aw and who performs the surgery Dr Ramon
Cortez he's the best neurosurgeon in
2000 miles he's the Dr IU if my own
family was on the table now we'll be
performing an awake craniotomy excellent
oh that's fine he was alive when they
drilled into his brain or awake awake I
said alive I meant awake when they
eventually drill into his
brain he will be awake in the future and
his brain get drilled into right the did
he's like been there done that saying
[__] that's why he was so chill in Saw
Three is because of
this it all makes sense
now and then they shave his head and
give him the little soul patch he comes
out of surgery with the soul
patch and that's all they
[Laughter]
did why
God nice it's almost like the Exorcist
in the like the actual medical procedur
is part of what's actually scary and c
and harsh yeah I'm sure the torture here
will be gross and disgusting but also
but this is pretty yeah this is pretty
still like cold and
yeah it's wild he's just watching them
like play around in his
brain no no don't turn it away don't you
don't need to see this it's going to get
pretty crazy on this end of things we're
going to put you back to sleep I'm going
to come down from 10 thought you
supposed to be awake yeah what happened
here what is this hi
there you did great that'll be$ 144
million we're two blocks away from aa's
hospital in case you need a transfusion
got your blood work it all looks good
John damn now you can make 10 more of
these mov
drink two a day one in the morning and
one at night in addition to my father's
treatment it contains a painkiller
you'll need for the next seven days
seven days after that what happens then
your whole life happens
then I never thought I'd feel this much
for John I'll we the second half of the
payment tomorrow morning thank you John
that's what you want to hear this is the
uest beatest Saw movie yet yeah how
about two more movies in the continuity
John oh buddy Cinema well and the tones
here are like way warmer way more like
orange yeah than the typical blue green
cold you
know damn for him being a million years
old like why do you have abs right now
bro hey man he's an engineer he's always
lifting parts and moving things get out
of here he's got Bobby Hill and a head
trap Dam yeah John we saw what you've
been doing he feels
rejuvenated oh he don't give up his oh
he doesn't like that one why not is he
going to give up his work
now
[Music]
takila just want to hear that whenever I
open some
tequila you have a gift card it's for a
friend a a Ros John you're so
[Music]
sweet I love that they gave him this
movie yeah right it's kind of funny cuz
the last movie barely had any traps and
I was like this is boring but this is
like so engaging this is great I love
this I love it well they know I mean
just like he is he is the best most
unifying part of the franchise yeah the
most interesting by far
hey Spanish getting better he's all
learning bar Mo
[Laughter]
Malo
see less M than
mine oh bad things Badness Badness and
Badness that happened to all of them and
now he's going to go teach him a lesson
s Revenge s
Revenge
where is everybody this looks like a
perfect Warehouse to do some killing to
play some
games oh they just got out of Dodge
yikes the FDA got him it's okay guys
they move around a lot this is totally
innocuous everything is fine it's took
it on the
road surgeons of
Tomorrow what
is oh Jesus
oh God they were watching a video or
wait on how to I am this is where he
gets the inspiration for a bunch of
videotaped hello welcome to section five
in our neurosurgery series human brain
is a mystery hundreds ofli oh yeah yep
yep yep yep this means that you'll be
floing in music oh my
god oh
oh take a good close look you got any
scarring back there or
anything oh
God
ooh oh
no damn they didn't do thing they didn't
do anything at all
wow could
fly all
right oo
those edits
damn why did the guy with the pancreatic
thing have a scar oh God I am I'm
wrecked right now maybe they were just
like well it's on the back of this guy's
head there's no way he'll be able to
check right wow that's so sick thank you
man have a good one course
than we didn't see them see him give
them money but yeah he just transferred
it digital well there's they definitely
got that money of course they did yeah
man
[__] hey baby game is on Revenge Revenge
R Revenge
Revenge yeah buddy my
god
oh
you oh my God oh my
God I've told you what you wanted to
know I've told you who you're looking
for no that ain't going to work
though oh
man yep now the game
begin let me give you the illusion of
Hope like you gave me
yeah
yes let's go hello Diego or should I
call
you Dr
Cortez
wow I'd like to play a game attached to
your arms are two explosive
devices yeah buddy sort of cancer a
malignancy that must be cut out for you
to
survive the blades cannot cut through
the galvanized cable but they can and
slic through flesh and muscle allowing
you to cut the cancer
away Jesus let's go and then just slide
it off your bones
right let's get some de
gloving you're screwed
buddy God just to have him right there
yeah that nod oh go ahead get on with it
this the first time we've SE seen him
actively watching in front of them and
they know that what's what's going
on except for jigs offw but like that
movie doesn't count oh god oh
yeah
no why does it take so long just do it
that I hate
it golly the cancer
my
[Music]
goodness now move those effects are
gnarly dude oh my God I want it oh my
[Music]
God it's exactly the experience I was
hoping for oh
God come on Dr
cabby God look at that come on
buddy you got it right yeah oh you were
running long time come on buddy speed it
up cuz I can't handle much more come on
now you're done dude you're done wow
dude to bite it out oh my God oh my God
kick it away kick it away well done
man all
right oh
wow you won you did it he did he's like
very good yes okay okayy someone wins
okay wow it's been a Min it's been a Min
since a win yeah man what happens
now detective I could use your
assistance in locating some people that
are in need of our
surfaces
oh all right love that he approached him
there with the like you survived
compassion yeah yeah I wonder if he's
going to be helping out for this or if
he's just going to go rest it
off is she the other doctor yeah
Valentin was the
nurse
damn okay damn oh my God you both about
to get jigsawed for completely different
reasons
[Music]
yeah oh oh yep nice
behind
you and the
graffiti guy are we going to do a
multi-person trap we must right everyone
involved God she was
prostitutes and junkies for this whole
operation no oh no hey no he just gave
him mistak right yeah each one of these
dogs is a good boy they're never going
to be in a trap all right they won't be
ever they appreciate
life don't tase me
bro
you had to go all this way just to take
your pills is that
secretive oh I can't wait for a pig mask
to come over up the top or the
[Music]
bottom look
up oh damn well done
[Music]
oh my God Jesus oh my God John wow well
yeah next week Margaret oh my God he
didn't even pay scheduled
already but I think that we might have
room for one more spot oh please no no
need to cry Margaret I'm not an angel
it's pure science
J oh you going to die horribly in a
really rough way honey awful ways this
is such an interesting twist I love it
John is the protagonist of this movie
what dude that's crazy well and she is a
terrific antagonist because she is so
you know kind of warm and and seem so
believable and trustworthy and Earnest
and then she's just a
raging giving people their worst times
yeah yeah
look at your beautiful house all filled
with li
money hope he's just standing there in
the field yeah right or the pig the pig
masks
yeah you can see me it doesn't matter
I'm going to get you
anyway nice love that love that this a
well chosen location house very
different setup from all the other ones
cuz like I don't even see a scenario
where there would be the traditional saw
twist you know it's not that kind of
film these surveillances are taking
place during the events of saw one
actually oh you can see yourself there
he is there he is oh
boy oh yeah oh here we go amazing it
doesn't matter where you stand
[Laughter]
yeah he just threw the rock don't
defraud people and glass
houses now the question is there it's
going to be the mask is it going to be
the mask is is John working alone or did
he calling some help for some friends
it's a good question I don't know that's
a
j that we got that's that's got to be
John yeah there he is who's this who's
this
onea oh my God hi girl oh we can't get
back together who are you
this is my associate
Amanda oh man shie Smith back in Action
yep is Hoffman here too get some rest
Cecilia you're going to need it you're
going to need
it yeah you are oh [__] you crazy ass oh
my God love it oh yeah oh yeah here we
go here we go this whole movie set in
Mexico that's wild my God why was back
here oh this is going to be gnarly it's
going to be
lit
man speak of the devil oh we're only
trying to help
you that game is over and a new game is
about to begin yep please listen to me I
beg you I beg you we had nothing to do
with this we didn't know what was going
on it was all her M I don't even know if
that's your real name it is my real name
it is
oh I meant no harm I would really like
to believe you you'll have a chance to
prove
yourself
a oh the key to your freedom is inside
inside that box it's a Jil saw I thought
you said there was a key he was speaking
metaphorically when I get out of here
I'm going to kill both of you
mother oh dang girl that is not the time
don't say that you're going to want to
really listen carefully to the rules in
order to pull that
[Music]
off the wire saw inside that box was
invented by an Italian physician
Leonardo jile it creates an
extraordinarily clean cut to the
[Music]
Bone yeah oh my God ow ow the daughter
line on your leg marks the spot are you
Cy the wire soil that's wrapped around
your neck will first cut into your skin
then your vertebral ligaments and
finally it'll sever your spinal
cord I got all the diagrams from from
your fake ass doctor
office you won't you wouldn't oh oh you
don't know who you messing with lady we
won't but Valentina might all of you oh
you promise dying people dying people
mhm yep get them you took advantage of
the only thing that they still possessed
who no John we've worked to heal people
John Kramer going to make me cry right
now my associate Amanda here has had to
look at your bank
records who would lose 34 people to you
did you heal any of those 34 people yeah
I want to know you've been doing this
larous dance now for more than 8 years
wow that's more than $8 million
wow we know everything we have
everything including the cash from your
house please help me please this is not
retribution it's a
Reawakening bars there are more than 5
lb of marrow in the human body all you
need is 3 o just suction it out it'll be
transferred to that device and it'll
deactivate the saw around your neck
don't hesitate cuz your time is
prescribed Choice words boy nice you'll
make it so long as you keep your
head I love
Amanda I love their Dynamic with each
other
this is not right not right the lecture
in moral
decency yeah how is she not just been
like I'm so sorry take all my money let
us go this was a mistake I'll never do
it again yet she's just like this was
wrong even if she did do that get it but
I might still at least like apologize
for being scr a raging
te what do we do
this set I really like it's like old
school and that this shot is it's cool
yeah where this that like a factory gu
what you mean though the setting is like
really tangible it feels like different
feels like we're somewhere else but it's
still like real grimy real something JN
could get his hands on you
yeah oh God the t t put it on God damn
it Valena T it
on come on girl oh my God stop panicking
oh my
God yep yep y y on yeah use some of
those fake medical skills you got this
it your leg how tight is that
tourniquet not very tight no not tight
at
all
[Applause]
boy I can't oh girl you running out of
time stop don't think
just
jeez each time oh boy oh my God this is
awful ow ow ow ow ow no no oh oh
boy
no there the
sound a good
workout bro you got to have like oh you
a full minute left you got
time wa oh my God she got her [__]
leg off dude well done well
done that'se oh girl you did it get that
b marrow out baby you got another job to
do
now you're running out of time oh girl
you about to bleed out let's do this
sucking it out of the stump oh my God
this is insane wouldn't you pass out
before you cut your leg off that's what
I'm saying probably maybe no there's no
shock in this
universe this is so nasty oh my God my
God
still no are you are you are you in a
bone are you getting actual marrow here
you getting marrow because it doesn't
look like you oh no there
there's oh my God no no after all this
no no no no no oh come on oh my god oh
Jesus Christ make it BR so hard me to
she going make it she ain't going to
make it
[Music]
no and there she blows oh man
nice jeez wow wow oh bummer off off off
with bummer you brought me into this you
brought me into this get it you get it
Gabby I'm not the one addicted to oxy am
I uh-oh they're turning on each
[Music]
other this is between two and three
right I think this is between one and
two if I'm not mistaken yeah I'm not
sure I think I think that's what it is I
heard a lot people say 1.5 when talking
about this do you want to keep going yes
the
pain just comes in waves oh oh man I'm
not ready to do this without you you are
ready and you can you even want to do it
without him and eventually you will sa
into his head right now a man of these
people deserve to be tested that lady
doctor deserves nothing everyone
deserves a chance you should know that
more than anyone yeah buddy the lighting
right now I love it they make him look
like John is very Angelic almost Godlike
with the choosing of the light in this
along with his like metaphorical pull of
teaching them a lesson what oh here we
go what are you doing no wait what no
you can see you guys wait why is
she she saw the first movie there's a
key hidden in there like how does she
she clearly knew this would happen and
she prepared for
this we have a rope
what you're crazy bro you're insane give
it up give
it hell no Jesus Christ oh okay just got
to pretend it is an actual rope and not
it and it's not going to slip right
through our fingers it's just a bloody
rope this is not s dude oh they want the
phone okay okay yeah they want that
phone this is
incredible never in a million years I
think I've seen this in a movie that's
great that's
great looking like the queen of Hell
over
here h a MAG kidna by
a
buddy now sit you been waiting to do
that haven't you you're right I'm a
total fraud but my Father John is real
teal and you know that he can save you
is that your concern
H I swear to God that's who I was trying
to call I was trying to call God they
got a good Ensemble for this too like I
like the other ensembles and stuff but
they're way more grounded in this yeah
everyone everyone is very good
yeah
oh this guy yeah I've come to get my
money back and I'm not going hey you oh
my nice so he
called o Nice Shot I was going to say I
guess we needed one cop in this movie
even if he's still a victim of
[Music]
something
oh just a prop okay okay smart to test
what he
[Music]
do
D oh right girl now you got to test him
too variable interesting I know you
Kramer brain cancer right solidarity
among the struggling in this movie what
are you doing here Parker I came to get
my money
back h oh my God enjoy the show join us
they were all con artists and we we were
the suckers yeah they gave for
everything all the money I had that was
for my family that money well don't
worry you're going to get it back what's
your life really mean to you Parker have
you ever thought about that because if
you find the meaning of your life what
you found is your soul yeah damn
philosophical John was trying to give Mr
SE as a a chance to make his choice I'm
going to give you an opportunity to do
something significant with your life
okay can you please talk to me please
talk to me you [__] you my God not that
those are yeah jeez Taste of the face
wow taser face taser
[Applause]
face everyone's laughing at you he's a
monster he's going to kill you the same
way he's going to kill all of us you
don't know John if you want any more of
my help keep your mouth shut about that
dang Amanda's helping you girl oh she
wants you to win shoot she sees
kinship is that how I don't shoot that
thief in the
face trust me Mr Sears in short order
she wish that you
had wow front row my man God hello
they've pulled me in so far I keep like
I forgot about it yeah forgetting to
think about these
things
oh oh oh my that's was on the what he
was drawing on the paper that he
[Music]
tossed oh she oh God that's creepy what
are we doing Billy oh my
man oh wow oh what a good shot that's
great Amanda prepare the puppet yeah I'm
like did he bring all his jigsaw saw
gear just in case or did he have it like
shipped out here no when he told her to
come she brought all the stuff that's
right of course of course course makes
perfect
sense oh the
camera yeah at least we bother to shave
a patch that just play me I'm not going
to touch
something whoa whoa whoa you must oo
touch that thing now the meat AR e
e place a big enough piece of your
cerebral tissue into the glass enzyme
tank and you win a piece of what gray
matter piece of your brain remember how
you reenacted the video buddy come on
now if you complete your task in less
than 3 minutes the enzymes will dissolve
the tissue to close a circuit this will
save your life jeez the brain is a
remarkably resilient T organ have their
brain removed only to have it rewire
itself so that the patient not only
survives but thrives
wa the only thing I have not provided is
your anesthetic but trust me you will
want to remain
alert
yeah is there a
c
is this is yes
oh my God
okay I don't I don't like those sound
that sound makes my teeth hurt
y'all Jesus Christ ow no thank
you oh
God ow ow ow dude who thinks of these
things this is wild
John Kramer oh oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my
God yeah buddy you got it you're doing
good you're doing so good you're doing
great you're doing so great yeah
kill I like the way they've sort of
updated the ghosts freak out effect that
was the very first old school cut
technique that we've seen in this movie
at least since the eyeballs yeah yeah oh
right eyeballs
oh
yeah my God yeah W oh my god
dude oh yep get a spoon get a spatula
get Spork out come on start
scooping start scooping I just have to
pretend just pretend it's a juicy soup
it's a soup it's fake it's a movie it's
fake I hate it I hate
it oh
my oh my goodness wiggle wiggle wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle
go oh my god dude I love there are
chemical reactions involved in this and
and H more brain more brain get more
brain more
brain yeah just start getting handfuls
man you're done son you're done oh what
are we oh my
God whoa I like the azte
yeah is it going to send his heart
rolling down the stairs oh my
God it's going to rip out his heart
right maybe not fry and
Maiden wow oh my God I'm dying you have
to face that but our work's not going to
hit and I'm trust trusting you
a carry
on these twoo how can I movie be so up
and have so much heart at the same time
I
know oh
wow I love these two being with this
franchise for so long like this is
beautiful I want you to go and free Mr
Sears and see if he'll play by the
rules that's Billy St God God nope nope
nope you have to take
it no we'll never get out of here
otherwise you have seen what's been
happening
uh hello Gabriella I want to play a game
no no stop it stop it
oh
whoa oh oh no oh H upside down oh okay
oh yep you're going to play now girl oh
oh oh
oh halfway to drone and quartered is
sort of reminiscent of Jigsaw remember
when they uh they had to hang and he
like oh no dude you got to play the rest
of the tape girl oh
[Music]
jeez
waa what this is going to spray tequila
at you drink as much as possible
although you all pretended to cure my
cancer I have spent years in treatment
chemotherapy
immunotherapy radiation whoa radiation
machines are not to be trifled
with oh my the only way out is to free
your hand and Ankle use the tool above
you flesh can be grafted it will not be
easy but then nothing worth having like
life is that a was going to try to help
her there's nothing do she got it
delayed only so long
I guess this one doesn't need a clock we
have to break your hand and Ankle oh
yeah I guess to fit it through right oh
God no no no no no stop with your foot
you'll swing out of the
way don't Drop It For The Love Christ
oh shouts out to Eric
matthewsa
ow ow ow ow ow oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh boy oh my God it's already
burning that's intense Oh my Jesus
goodness what a
crazy it worked oh
[Music]
jeez waa girl you you definitely got
skin cancer now
something yeah you knew it you knew it
of course you knew hey hey no that was a
great reaction so
exhausted come on It come on we go oh
God she's dangling so high though yeah
she going die from the fall but she's
going to hurt herself for sure I don't
think she'll yeah right I think she'll
be okay um maybe just a broken leg ow ow
[Music]
ow okay the fall wasn't that bad it
wasn't too high I guess as far as games
go that wasn't like the worst they gave
her semblance of a chance okay play
time's over of course man why buddy the
keys to Cecilia chains you don't need
the keys she's not going
anywhere also you came in ready to kill
her what the what the f man
did she unload the gun F like she
unloaded
it it's an interesting thread to
include thought you forgot about
me not a chance oh no he was a plant a
sucks he was a plan all along I should
have called that out the second he
showed up and he was in the the room
already I was like do they have a fake
patient here just to sell it come on Old
Man lock yourself in oh
[Music]
no this was part of the plan a cage is
going to form around him he'll descend
into the floor
safe we need to get her to a hospital
she won her game and she deserves to
live her injuries need medical treatment
do they you wouldn't know anything about
that though are you the killer dude
really oh my God you're the worst no no
no no no no no no
no
wow what you just spent all that time
helping her oh what a snake why would
you do that what a true snake you're
going to have to get the money back from
me before you two can split her it's
upstairs you know she's eventually going
to kill you too right Amanda don't talk
to Amanda that way when I realized who
you really were s and now the great John
Kramer is going to die in one of his own
traps there's some Wicked irony
sure what is this insurance who we got
who we got who be
oh who is it is it your boy oh oh no
it's the boy soccer player get in here
kid the kid who helped you know this ho
is dead in 2 months but I want him to
suffer I want his last memory to be
watching someone innocent
die you've learned [__] from your time
here hey Carlos hi how you
doing see they're about to kill or
traumatize the hell of that boy
obviously she's going to use his
innocent blood to torture
John
uhoh
whoa oh she is sick go this is I did not
see any I any of this the boy is inest
exactly so if you let him die it's all
on you this is crazy you might want to
tell the kid the rules before we start
he's not a player in any of this oh come
on John do the scary
voice you really want the boy to play
without hearing the rules I don't I
think he's done a
farewell
oh John I will C his throat oh he ain't
so frail right now
[Music]
dude you've got 10 seconds or I hit the
Lev myself and I don't have a silly
moral cult like you trust me oh we know
don't worry I trust you fine I've
gathered no how do you get out of this
bro I don't even know you know he has to
he came
back oh my
god
oh Wesley Hoffman
someone yeah right where where where's
Dr
[Music]
Gordon whoa okay
what I have never been more engaged in a
Saw movie in my entire life right yeah
this is actually
insane no
buo
Jesus what what a P4 why is that blood
blooding
I don't want it I don't want it turn it
off is that all the discarded
blood I can't believe they're actually
going through with it I thought he was
going to get out of the Trap before it
started they really got the
drop maybe this is the test that shows
them we need another guy on the team
right
yeah oh my God this poor child that's
why he says no holla cuz if John keeps
pulling no cuz it's going to go back on
the kid now oh he's going to help him
out yeah oh
kiddo oh little dude
no oh my goodness stop
stop a dying man and a little kid wow
this is insane just in case you forgot
how evil they were these two with the
freaking
G let's going get the
money oh my goodness getting too much
for my man over here come on once I
heard your voice over that speaker I
knew I'd be fine can't believe they fell
for the whole damn thing hul L and
sinker nope I don't like this wide angle
lens but if you were the last player who
was supposed to be on the other side of
that blank with you my man ah
[Music]
okay
what
oh
[Music]
baby oh what do we got one more tape
what do we have here don't tell me John
saw this coming the whole time
dude this has to be a fail safer where
Mone they you back
[Music]
already Jesus oh
wow yeah there that
music oh my
god I've never been more happy to hear
that music on my life yeah oh my God
yeah my God there's no bullets
honey
what oh my oh my oh my you are a warrior
my
boy a warrior join my team what did they
know about
you new passage of the theme Parker SE
okay he was in on it he's a Handler and
he's cilia too oh I was able to find the
man you asked for
oh but
par you'll have to find another way oh
voice Goa yeah they left you know yeah
they wouldn't just leave the phone for
no reason love that
yeah Peterson Parker Sears yes you've
each been working grift playing a role
working together continuing to play out
your scam never realizing that you have
been the marks all night
[Music]
[Applause]
long let's go hey baby hey you have
played your last con game but not your
last game the two of you have worked
together to destroy others nope now you
will work against each
other only one can survive it's going to
be Cecilia she's going to be like
bye take turns
forever I thought you forgot about
[Music]
me a wa jeez
man ooh
W cile
yeah no
oh his eyes
wow so she gets to live
John
you're not going to survive in there for
long you put your head the rest of her
body is going to
be here kid oh yeah exactly a go and
live
[Music]
buddy don't like that she kids to live
yeah is there is there an extra beat
coming here
maybe oh my God wait I have an idea but
but but let's wait and
see into the
sunrise saw X
wow okay this she might she may be
living with some burns on her face
though so that's a plush she doesn't
have all her beauty still Kevin gr grter
love you Kevin gr well done sir that was
great that was terrific nice job Kevin
yeah yeah buddy hey man I mean I gotta
give it to him like Kevin grer has has
or grutter however you say it has
directed he's probably the most Darren
Bowsman did four of them and Kevin did
at least three as director now so like
he's one of the most really Kevin yeah
cuz cuz Darren Bowsman did two through
four and then spiral and then Kevin grer
did six and 3D and this really oh well
this one what about the writers though
cuz this one was like legs better in
like every way this is the writers of at
least jigsaw and spiral I want to say so
this
is what the happened what gonna say you
had Lee wanell uh writing he edited it
too Kevin which is and Charlie cler's
done all the scores yeah Kevin grer do
direct has edited
everyone I think except the ones he
directed and except spiral um yeah this
is like leagues better than like this
the oh oh
what hold it what do we got what's
happening oh is it his final game with
her like oh no
yes
it's that's what I was wondering you ask
where's your skull yeah oh thank you
detective for locating my fellow cancer
p
patient yes it
was men hello out of all the men to
cheat you pick John
Kramer please don't kill me that's the
last thing that you should be worried
about
now I want to play I want to play a
game whoa
oh
wow
Dam oh not bad all right loved it love
it loved it wow and you know what else I
love you guys hello there esteemed
viewer of the real rejects I Greg Alba
language connoisseur and worldly
gentleman I'm here to bestow upon you
the secrets of Babel the language app
that transforms mere mortals into
linguistic gods in just three weeks why
Babel you inquire my dear friends in
this age of monolingual mundanity
mundanity mity mundanity Babel is our
Beacon of Hope crafted by an army of
over 150 language experts their lessons
are like linguistic caviar Rich refined
and oh so satisfying personal tail of
Triumph I once whispered sweet nothings
in Spanish or for the lame and espanol
to my wife courtesy of Babel her
reaction well I'll tell you she was
utterly Bewitched Greg you silver tongue
devil no paraphrasing she exclaimed such
vocabulary as I bass in the glory of my
perfect PR nunciation this Babel isn't
just about learning words it's about
embracing the art of conversation with
podcasts live classes and a veritable
smorgus sport of interactive
lessons I know the words I'm saying and
their speech recognition it's like
having a personal language Butler
ensuring every syllable is impeccably
crisp that breaks yourselves for an
offer of monumental proportions here's a
special limited time deal for our
viewers and listeners to get you started
right now get 55% off your Babel
subscription but again only for our
viewers at babel.com
rejects 50 5% off at babble.com
rejects spelled b a
bb.com reject rules and restrictions May
apply join me the Greg Alin the
adventure of language Mastery at Babel
we shall not just learn no nay we shall
conquer the world of communication or as
they say in
[Music]
Spanish we're done with this ad all
righty time to get a little bit serious
so around the holiday season we often
focus on getting gifts for others but
it's it's also important to consider the
gifts that we give to ourselves
personally I found that maintaining
mental health balance is a continuous
Journey cuz like I've mentioned before
I've been diagnosed with type to bipolar
ADHD and PTSD and in a lot of ways I've
also grown up in the last few years on
camera with you guys and therapy has
been a crucial part of my life before
the channel even and like many of you my
anxiety and depression seems to magnify
this time of year still don't quite
understand the winter Blues but it does
however therapy does help me navigate
the ups and downs and stay grounded for
the most part and while I have my own
approach to therapy I understand
everyone's path is unique and that's why
we proud to be sponsored by betterhelp
this week it's an online platform that
makes therapy accessible and tailor to
your needs and I know a few people who
have discovered therapy via betterhelp
and it has been transformative you start
with a questionnaire that helps match
you with a licensed therapist and the
best part and an important part you can
switch therapist anytime ensuring the
right fit for you better help is all
about convenience and flexibility it
fits into your schedule and it's all
online so whether you're looking to
start therapy for the first time or
continue your journey better help can be
a great option so in the season of
giving remember to give yourself what
you need to with better help take that
step towards your better self so you can
visit betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off
your first month that's
betterhelp.com
rejects take care and stay healthy
reject Nation happy holidays and now I
just have to say that saw 10 is so good
oh my
God you guys I'm ready to just be like
10 out of 10 this one this is like X Out
of X this is
yes you did it you did it you did it
like thank you I was in it from like the
beginning to the very end and now
there's like times where I wasn't saying
anything cuz I just did I was so pulled
in and I was so engulfed I love the way
they played like cinematic this is also
I feel like the most cinematically shot
even though which is surprising to me
that you're seeing Kevin he directed the
other ones I really liked how they
played with the lighting especially in
regards to John they made him like he
was always backlit a little bit like he
was Angelic in this and I love how to me
John is the person that I'm like no he's
the best person in this even
though he's like John Kramer who's done
all these weird games with this movie
really they did like a joker thing where
you're like show his life and now show
how he got here and I think I really was
thrown into Jon's moral code the most in
this one even though they've placed it
in other movies saw X brought it to the
Forefront and man oh man you did a great
job hundo P absolutely agree you guys
get to it yeah man I feel like they they
really changed the formula of this Saw
movie and like granted all of them have
had their own variations of the story
but they started to get a little bit
repetitive as far as like the motifs of
which they would use but this one was
drastically different from all the other
ones with the fact that he was like the
front and center and like I was
surprised because we've never never had
him as like the up in front protagonist
before but to see that and you get you
to root for him was incredible the way
it was shot was incredible the traps
were incredible seeing his moral code in
full force in the in the sense that you
know we really get to be in his shoes
because these people have personally
wronged him which was something like
we've never really seen before and from
this kind of franchise especially from
this kind of franchise and Amanda was
was great and like the the fact that
even though they haven't played the
characters to this extent in close to
what like 15 or so years something
around
there it's almost it's going on 20 years
now almost 20 years 2004 was saw one
yeah was saw one but the fact that
there's able to just slip back right
into them I know JN has like been
something continuous with like
flashbacks or short appearances but the
fact that he was like the front and
center and also Amanda being there with
and they're they were able to stay true
to who those characters were m not from
like a revisionist standpoint but like
authentically where we met them in that
place and yeah man everything was just
so gripping like there was kind of how
Tera was saying I was locked in the
whole time my jaw was like you'll watch
it back my jaw was dropped for like I
damn near like 30 seconds like at some
point cuz I was just like so enthralled
in what was going to happen and even
though we know that they're going to
live cuz this is obviously an in between
cool the stakes in which and how they
played it was just so stable and so
enthralling I was just I was blown away
and I think this movie I'm not I'm not
sure if it's um oh something I am sure
of is the fact that it's damn it's in
the top three easily if not if not the
best one but something I wasn't sure of
going in was how it was going to keep us
engaged in that and I feel like rooting
it in his his experience was the best
way to go about that and yeah it was it
was incredible it was incredible and and
one last thing I'll say is that because
we've watched 10 of these it makes this
one so much more rewarding because we've
seen this journey from its Inception in
one through 10 and I think maybe it
could stand on its own still enjoy it
but I think it's that much more
enriching because we've gone through
John and Amanda and Hoffman and getting
to this point
just French Kiss absolutely kiss AB both
both kinds of kiss both kind of kisses
it makes me curious because I think this
one has the best opportunity to stand on
its own um along with the first one I
think those two have the most Standalone
ability barring like Spiral because
that's clearly kind of in a pocket side
Universe um and but the the cool thing
is while I'm sure you could do a rewatch
with this in the middle I think as much
as they have said like the producers
kind of realize like oh maybe killing a
off was a
mistake um and and part of wonders if
you could have this movie as exactly as
it is make the impact that it makes
without all the time that we have spent
the fact that we miss this guy like we
already have enough to stand on in terms
of Tobin Bell is a great actor he
clearly cares about this role he's well
documented as having you know given a
lot of his own creativity to it and so
10 year or or not 10 years 20 almost 20
years of Saw and the 10th installment it
almost feels like a very appropriate
full circle to do something like this
and to have a movie that yeah hands over
the focus hands over the narrative to
the guy it it almost it's kind of
reminded me of like the freshness that
like a saw two hat where it's like oh
damn we know who this guy is and now
we're going to spend time with him for
most of the movie and here I I love the
compliment of the first movie he's not
talking to anybody but he's running the
game he's on the floor in the room and
in this one he's in the room giving the
a dress like literally just watching and
orchestrating and kind of doing it on
the fly a little bit in a way that felt
very palpable and tangible and I think
it fits nicely between these earlier
installments I believe it is supposed to
be between you know at least one and two
and uh and yeah the way it's like they
didn't even H I wasn't even thinking
about daging or anything like clearly
they look a bit older than they do in
Saw 2 and I didn't care at all because
the emotional quality and the attention
to detail on the characters their
relationship back and forth was really
nicely done Hoffman makes for a perfect
little Easter egg because obviously
might have some involvement here um and
so yeah this was able to do so many
different things that are like that you
would want out of a commemorative sequel
of sorts like but it has fan service
without ever feeling like it's trying to
Pander fan service you know and uh and
yeah having this real kind of uh uh
deliberate pace and allowing you to be
with John on his journey really
experience you know what his life is
like living with his cancer and the
other people around and the solidarity
they show between them him and the other
Survivor or the other people who are you
know trying to become survivors
basically and then you know it's like
Amanda and Gabriella and all that stuff
there's so many like great little
attentions to character in detail and
then you know you bring in all the other
trappings of you know the stylistic
flourishes and the ghost trails and the
freakouts and the traps and even if this
doesn't have the most outlandish or the
most complicated traps necessarily I
thought the way that they showed Jon's
eye for it like this is the best use of
a fake out like imagination trap because
the eyeball vacuum is probably the most
recognizable thing from this movie each
movie has like a trap you might refer to
I feel like the eyeball is the is like
the most iconic that this movie has in
terms of just like a striking visual
with the tubes and all that and using
all the marketing too yeah totally and
so having that be a beat where it
doesn't actually happen to the guy but
you you see what Jon's motivation is in
watching him and also how he's starting
to formulate what the Trap might be
because he's noticing the person in
traction on the bed and then that
informs the finger snaps and it's just
like little things like that that makes
all the sense that we couldn't really do
before when we're doing like yeah each
one of these like police procedural and
we're always going you know crazy sort
of semi melodrama semi like super
convoluted twists and I love all that
and I thought that this managed to do so
much classic saw while also structuring
out a movie that felt different and felt
very conscientious of like yeah maybe a
variable mighten maybe this somebody
might find you out here in a place where
you don't have as much control as you
would just back home conducting
something like this and uh and yeah like
the group of them the contrast of like
she's clearly guiding this whole
procedure for the grift and then she's
got to freaking guide them all through
these traps and and I I you know I I
think I'm curious to hear how you guys
left off at least with the main
antagonist you know she doesn't die she
doesn't get subject to the worst trap
but I still feel pretty Satisfied by the
end that this person has been
appropriately sort of torn down and
scarred by her own horrific choices oh
yeah I mean she's got burns on her face
she doesn't have any of the money and
I'm sure the rest of her body in there
is probably messed up oh yeah and I'm
I'm glad that she has to walk around
like that like I'm like yeah go walk
around because now it's like the scars
show your evil cuz I hope people have to
go hey what real quick what happened to
the what happened to you to you and then
maybe she has to go well I'm a raging
SE uh and that's why but uh yeah how did
you feel about her getting you feel good
but like it's like I feel he he does
like that she's still alive I knew died
yeah I like get her outsides match her
insides but she was like the worst like
this is the first time because Grant
we've watched a lot of Saw movies at
this point we've seen a lot of of
douchebags and and and a-holes in this
movie but by far she's the worst out of
all of them hatable the most hatable and
I was like wow I feel like this is the
first time we've gotten like a straight
up villain to oppose jigsaw in a in a
sense not necessarily matching wits but
like someone who makes this guy who does
horrible things Justified because she is
so equally or more than him just evil
just evil just because cuz money and
yeah man I granted I liked the movie a
lot I that's the only thing it doesn't
change my rating at all but I was like
oh I wish she would have gotten her
kupets because she sucked she does I
also feel like all of the casting in
this great job Nancy I mean I'm like
always trying to hit up Nancy be like yo
girl call me in for your stuff but I
love this all put me in
put me in whatever n does great great
stuff shout out to you uh but everyone
in this was really really grounded I've
not seen that and a lot of the saws
there's certain times you have seen us
laugh out loud at the way that the
actors have said lines and we don't do
that cuz you guys love that detective
and saw 3D he he like oh my God we were
mad we were actually we laughed out loud
we were so angry about it like how is
this supposed to be taken seriously and
that did not happen here obviously at
all
which is so great but I also feel like
the writers uh when's the last time what
number did we see Hoffman in the last
time we saw Hoffman he in seven last
time he's in seven so we've seen eight
eight and nine was the we didn't like
eight right I was madw eight was jigsaw
then nine technically spiral with rock I
was mad both times I think so the
writers I feel like learn the lessons uh
there slightly because this had a really
great ending and I know uh Jos stolberg
name has popped up I think on seven and
eight I follow him on the Twitter and
the grams he's a cool guy you guys um
should too he's great but um this one
really brought it all together and I'm
really glad that they were like let's
choose Hoffman and Amanda and not that
weird guy that we put in eight to just
that was he was he was here the whole
time you guys know that I was mad about
it for a week um thank you for tossing
that out the
window yeah and and just bringing back
these characters that we really like and
bringing this story to life that you
knew like this sells this is one of the
best saws so con congrats they didn't
try to over complicate it either they
brought it back to basics well keeping
it just uh complicated or just um
intricate enough to be like the
satisfying experience because like
that's finale we were on the edge of our
seats and I was like I don't know how I
was going to get out of this and then
the fact that there was this twist cuz I
remember saying that earlier in the
movie like I don't know how there's
going to be a Twist in this movie and
sure enough it was that exactly there
was and it was it was it was good yeah
it's like it's well proportioned for the
most part because they would have some
kind of contingency it makes sense that
they would do that it makes sense that
they might you know knowing that they
have a variable to work with with this
guy yeah that they might try and proof
it and I guess my only question I'm left
with is that if this woman is Left Alive
and she knows who he is uh I I would
have to imagine that in my own head
Cannon maybe Hoffman just comes and
finishes it something or different rules
yeah you know because because I I was
almost expecting and I love that they
did the post credits tag with the guy
and that was a great I think you one of
you guys yeah was like wait a minute but
he had the scar what's going on with
that and I love that they didn't forget
about that and part of me was expecting
like oh if there's a sting maybe it'll
be her re-up into some kind of gruesome
trap but I think what I think it's a
neat choice and I'm going to chew on it
for a while but partly because it it
shows Jon's adherence to his own
philosophy yeah so it's like she played
the game by the rules despite all this
you know despite you know usurping the
game and mocking it and being the worst
in the process and yet still uh even
though we are probably all right there
with Amanda being like she deserves
nothing and she only proves that further
and further you know they get to walk
off as you know a momentary little
family in a way that you know it's
bright there's Angelic light but it
didn't feel too cheesy and I feel like
they they kept the cheese just the right
amount in this and for the most part
yeah this as a reinvention goes I think
is really lovely because it's not about
let's Beef It Up and let's make it more
sleek and Mak make it crazier it's no
let's take our time and make the most
like cinematic film that we have made
since the first movie yeah cu the first
movie has this charm of like yeah it's
it's clearly a grungy lowbudget movie
but it's got cinematic aspirations on
its mind not to say the others aren't
cinematic but there's a different
popcorn quality that comes in whereas
this yeah definitely feels like in some
ways tonally this is probably like the
best made and conceived and executed in
a lot of ways I mean you can't do this
probably without the first one and I
think doing this is number 10 and having
the push pull of like John's gone we've
got him in flashbacks it's good to have
him but it's problematic that he's dead
I think that helps this movie really
kind of earn all of its aspirations and
the things that it attempts to do so
yeah like as both a fan of Saw who will
take you know a schlock saw happily love
that side of the franchise I also love
you know Cinema and I love that they
caringly because this has also been
something of a family Endeavor you know
it's like even though there are 10 of
these there's been you know you've had
the same few writers
for stretches you've had the same
handful of people guiding the direction
for stretches and you have like the same
composer throughout the same editor
throughout and it's able to grow but I
think really organically maintain its
core elements and as a compared to any
other horror franchise and often they'll
have you know a shepherd of some kind
but this feels weirdly like the most
sort of organically earnestly kind of
Spun and guided by just this little
group of people who make
movies cuz you watch the credits and you
just see so many like names and you know
and hats off to Kevin grard man like
he's he's been here since the first one
and uh and I love that I mean I I'm a
I'm a Darren Bowsman fan for various
reasons and I like his saw joints but I
feel like James Juan and Kevin grard are
probably like the best stamps and then
you have Darren Bowman who helped really
flesh out what this franchise would
become and brought a lot of cool
stylistic flourishes too but it's yeah
it's just been cool to see both on
screen what they've done over time and
especially with this and the creatives
behind it and how that's all kind of you
know become this little group this this
band of you know game makers the saw hor
people you guys did a great job you made
a cinematic thing with lots of dope
games and we loved it you had the horror
aspect it wasn't over the top we didn't
need it we want to sit with story like
we did in the first and the second one
we finally got that we've been yelling
about it for weeks so yay I love this
movie like I really thank you thank you
thank you this has a this has a not only
like a fresh score but it has like a
legit like it's like 809 like close to
90 or something or at least when it came
out like it was a lot of reviews and a
like solidly fresh percentage which like
blew my mind I never thought I'd say
this but this has I've seen a lot of
movies this year and this has a solid
chance of making my top 10 I
know I predicted that on the live stream
this afternoon I was like I had seen it
yet but I think saw will make my list
yeah man like thank you guys for making
this film we love you so much don't
forget to leave a like leave a comment
tell us how cool we are tell us how much
you also love this movie we are at the
end of our journey right now but maybe
they'll make an 11th and we'll be back
oh there'll be more as long as to and
Bell's alive make these and and find a
way to keep the heart this is a Saw
movie with the heart like how crazy is
that like make make that we love you
guys so much make sure you buy a t-shirt
reject naations shop.com
um also I forgot to say this uh if
you're listening on Apple or Spotify as
a podcast make sure you rate this
episode we love it we need get those
ratings up you know what I mean five
stars baby join patreon if you haven't
already we love you so much and we will
see you on the next one bye
bye